nowadays when you pay your taxes it's
done in several ways either you get a
bill at the end of the tax year or it
comes out of your paycheck before you
even see it
of course this level of bureaucratic
sophistication didn't exist during the
medieval period which raises the
question how were medieval taxes
actually collected how did a ruler
extract taxes from their subjects and
what sort of things were subject to tax
well across Europe many states at
varying levels of centralization which
affected how taxes were collected one
state which spanned thousands of miles
and also the entire medieval period was
the eastern Roman Empire often called
the Byzantine Empire and the Bumble
focus on this is because it was a well
developed state with both a large urban
and rural population so how were these
taxes actually collected well to
everyone surprised the people who bore
the brunt of taxation with the peasantry
and there were two major forms of
taxation in the Byzantine Empire the
first was rent which a peasant paid to
their local Lord in return for the right
to use land and the second was the
teller men on the household tax which
was paid to the central government rent
was based upon the value and
productivity of the land in question and
for the most part was determined by the
Lord the household tax was determined by
central tax collectors who would travel
across the Empire and take inventory of
who had what the tax collectors would
then leave and come back soon after to
collect the demanded taxes and the
responsibility lay with the Lord to make
sure it was paid but if the tax
collectors and the Lord would then make
a note of how much was paid and who paid
it to make sure the taxes weren't
collected twice and off they go
now there were three ways in which
peasants could pay their taxes
the first was simply in coin the second
was in kind like handing over the
equivalent value of their produce and
the third was via unpaid labor and this
was used for things like the
construction of public roads or churches
in case you're wondering the nobility
and the clergy were given what were
called privileges which reduced their
tax burden all of this makes it sound
like the Byzantine Empire was simply
able to tax the peasantry up to the hilt
but they did have protections the
government knew that an unhappy
unproductive peasantry would destabilize
the Empire which is why there were
limitations on how much they could be
taxed in regular peacetime that said in
times of war and war was quite common
special taxes could be levied the most
egregious of these were the farm levy an
extra tax on farm land and the seizure
of church property mostly its gold
reserves and this was a right in which
all Byzantine emperors held because
legally the entire Empire was their
personal property and everyone else only
held it with their permission it wasn't
just a peasantry
was subject to taxation another major
revenue stream for the Empire was
taxation or merchants in their trade
unlike the taxation of the peasantry
local Nobles weren't included and it was
the sole purview of the central
government and so to summarize that's
how the Byzantine government would
collect its taxes via state pay
bureaucrats who traveled the Empire to
assess land valleys and levy attacks
accordingly the Lords of the peasantry
in question would then be required to
collect the taxes and paid the next time
that the collectors were about what's
the level of Taxation vary depending on
trade location and era one thing was
consistent nobody liked paying them I
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching with the special thanks
to my patreon supporters who you can see
on screen here and with an extra special
thanks to James Bissonnette David
archaeologist party-boy Co Danny Maloney
Colin Castleman Rob Waterhouse are in
the white Michael Reynolds archway an
emperor chris wicker Gustav Swan Gareth
Turner spinning three plates David
Silverman Winston Cawood Maggie packs
Kowski Christian check' Anthony Beckett
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell and Ike